-Welcome to the show.
-Great to be here.
-You just got back from D.C.
yes?
-Just got off Amtrak.
I'm sure you do that trip
a fair amount.
You grew up here.
-Grew up in Brooklyn.
-You grew up in Brooklyn.
You represent Brooklyn,
part of Queens.
Brooklyn, I imagine,
has changed a fair amount
since you grew up there?
-Absolutely.
Brooklyn's a great place.
You know, we gave the worl
Jackie Robinson,
Shirley Chisholm,
Coney Island...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Junior's Cheesecake,
and The Notorious B.I.G.
-Yeah. Not a bad bunch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a pretty --
a pretty good combination.
-That's pretty good, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And does it still feel like
home when you get back there
-It does.
It's changing a lot.
And one of the challenges that
you know,
we all are working through
is making sure that
we can maintain the diversit
that has made Brooklyn
such a special place.
You know,
we want to continue to be
a collection of neighborhood
where working families,
middle-class folks,
senior citizens, young peopl
who are starting out, artist
can continue
to call Brooklyn home.
So we have
a real affordable housing crisis
that we have to address.
-You obviously mentioned, righ
there, the value of diversity.
Well, you talked last nigh
about Donald Trump
and his comments
about Ilhan Omar,
your colleague.
What's your response
to when you saw that
and, also, your response
to what seems to be
a more muted reaction to i
from your Republican colleagues?
-Well, those are very dangerou
and divisive remarks
that were made.
And words have consequences,
particularly when delivere
by the so-called
leader of the free world.
And there are people
who he can inspire and incit
to do violent things.
And so I think my colleagues o
the Republican side of the aisle
would do well in calling u
their president and saying
"Cut it out. You're going to
get someone hurt."
We feel like we're going t
continue to denounce
the outrageous behavior
when it occurs,
but we need partners
on the other side of the aisle
And we need people to star
saying, "You know what?
There
are certain things where -
this is not a Democratic issue
or a Republican issue --
it's an American issue,
and let's put --
let's put America -- let's put
country ahead of party."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You...
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Obviously, that --
one of the stories this week
was -- was Donald Trump
sort of calling out the squad,
these four progressive members
of the -- of Congress.
Earlier in the week, it seemed
like there was some conflict
within the Democratic Party.
Progressives may be feelin
a little bit overlooked
by leadership
or maybe leadership
working to undercut
the enthusiasm
from maybe progressive ideas
I know you guys
put out a statement today,
different fractions --
different factions,
I should say,
of the Democratic Party.
Is there --
Is there internal conflict
in the party right now?
-Well, we represent the gorgeous
mosaic of the American people.
And so, from time to time,
there are going to be
differences of opinion
because
we are incredibly diverse.
This is
the most diverse Congress
in the history of the country.
More women serving in Congress
than ever before.
[ Cheers and applause ]
More African-Americans,
more Latinos.
[ Cheers and applause ]
More Asian-Americans,
more Native American women
and more members
of the LGBTQ community
than ever before.
And the diversity
is only on the Democratic side
-Yeah.
-And as a result of that -
-They have more --
I think they have more "Dans
than ever before.
[ Laughter ]
-That's absolutely right.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But despite
our different life experiences
and the differences
of perspective,
we're united behind
a common purpose.
We have a
"for the people" agenda.
We want
to lower healthcare costs.
We want to protect
the more than 130 million people
who have pre-existing
conditions,
and the Trump administration
wants to take away
that healthcare protection
That's reckless.
We're going to stop it.
We want to drive down
the high cost of
lifesaving prescription drugs.
We want
a real infrastructure plan
that we believe can create up to
16 million good paying jobs.
These are the things
that unite Democrats
and will continue to unite u
moving forward
against
the aggressive conservatis
that's coming out
of 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue.